أذن الرئيس بايدن ورئيس الوزراء الكندي
جاستن ترودو بالاشتراك
بإسقاط
جسم مجهول كان يحلق فوق
شمال كندا يوم السبت ،
وقال الزعيم في تصريحات إن الإسقاط كانت
المرة الثالثة خلال أسبوع التي
تدافع فيها طائرات مقاتلة أمريكية
لإسقاط طائرة.  الجسم الذي دخل
المجال الجوي الأمريكي ، تم رصد الجسم الذي تم إسقاطه يوم
السبت فوق كندا لأول مرة
فوق ألاسكا ليلة الجمعة
وفقًا للبنتاغون وتم
إسقاطه في النهاية من قبل الطائرات المقاتلة الأمريكية
فوق كندا بعد مراقبته لمدة 24
ساعة.  يقول المسؤولون إنه لا
يزال من غير الواضح ما هو الجسم ،
لكن الحادث يأتي بعد يوم واحد فقط
من كشف البيت الأبيض والبنتاغون
أن الرئيس بايدن أمر
بإسقاط جسم طائر آخر مجهول
يوم الجمعة قبالة سواحل ألاسكا.
أفاد بعض الطيارين الذين تم إعدادهم للتحقيق في الأمر أن مستشعرات طائراتهم قد
تأثرت وقال آخرون إنه
لم يكن من الواضح كيف كان الجسم
يدفع نفسه الآن ، كما
يأتي الحادث الكندي أيضًا بعد أسبوع واحد بالضبط من
إسقاط الجيش الأمريكي بناءً على أوامر بايدن كما كان متوقعًا.  بالون تجسس صيني
قبالة سواحل كارولينا الجنوبية ،
ليس من الواضح ما إذا كان الجسم الذي
أُسقط يوم السبت فوق كندا مرتبطًا
بالبالون الصيني أو الجسم الذي
أُسقط يوم الجمعة ، لكن المسؤولين الأمريكيين قالوا
يوم السبت إن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي سيساعد
في التعافي والتحليل.  الحطام في جميع
الحوادث الثلاثة في محاولة للحصول على
فكرة أفضل عن ماهية هذه الأشياء
وما هي قادرة بالفعل على ناتاشا
برتراند سي إن إن واشنطن